nous allons y revenir car tout de suite
je voudrais vous proposer avec maryse
burgot et gilles jacquier de suivre une
famille de cuxac qui depuis 24 heures
vivait un véritable cauchemar elle
cherchait son fils de 11 mois dont elle
était sans nouvelle pour cette famille
le cauchemar vient de se terminer par
une bonne nouvelle ils sont sans
nouvelles de leur bébé de 11 mois depuis
trois jours
il est 23 heures hier soir dans la salle
des fêtes du village d'ouveillan sylvie
et florian clairac ne porte aucune
attention aux pompiers et militaires qui
se restaurent dans ce centre mise à la
disposition des rescapés de la
catastrophe
florian et sylvie attendent des
nouvelles de leur fille fou dingue
non
tous ceux qui sont réfugiés dorian et
son grand-père disparu à cuxac au moment
de la montée des eaux ne figure sur
aucune liste de rescapés et ne peut
résulter pour faire un brin de pendant
l'autre du froid il était pleine charge
par les familles donc on n'a pas
forcément tous les noms le bébé et son
grand père sont donc peut-être rescapés
mais réfugier dans une maison qu'on paie
du téléphone c'est le petit matin dans
la salle des fêtes d'ouveillan les
parents de dorian sont épuisés les
bénévoles appellent tous les centres
toutes les familles d'accueil recensés
un enfant qui on n'a plus de nouvelles
il s'appelle de clairac commencer par un
taux bien d'orient et puis enfin à 11h
ce matin c'est la fin du cauchemar
voyez bien et j'en ai dit qu'il fallait
pas désespérer dorian est à l'abri il a
été évacué avec son grand-père et une
partie de sa famille par les sapeurs
pompiers la maison située à cuxac et à
quelques kilomètres du village
d'ouveillan les premières retrouvailles
avec le bébé se feront dans la
discrétion
pendant ce temps la famille explique
pourquoi il ne pouvait pas prévenir les
parents sur un toit pas sur le toit de
sous le toit n'a pas rempli par
téléphone n'avait pas d'eau pas
d'électricité on avait une bouteille de
vin goûté tu te ranger tout ce qu'on a
vu l'enfant d'orient et tout sourire lui
ne se souviendra évidemment jamais de ce
week end d'intempéries du mois de
novembre
ses parents eux n'oublierons jamais que
pendant trois jours ils furent sans
nouvelles de leur fils unique